imagine a friend of yours says let's go
bowling tomorrow night if you like
bowling you might say all right let's
make a plan let's decide where to go
when to meet things like that but now
imagine the same friend says let's have
gone bowling last night you wouldn't
start making plans you'd start wondering
about the sanity of your friend we don't
think that we can make plans for
yesterday in the same way that we can
make them for tomorrow
that's because time has a direction
there's an arrow of time that points
from the past to the future that tells
us what direction time flows in and
scientifically we actually understand
how the arrow time works pretty well
well we don't understand is why it
exists at all why there is an arrow of
time in our universe if you think about
a cup of coffee with some cream you
don't know that you can mix coffee and
cream together very easily you can put a
spoon in stir it around the cream and
the coffee will mix together no problem
what never happens is that you start
with cream and coffee mixed together you
put a spoon in you stir it and they
unmix that's because there's a direction
to things that happen in the real world
you can mix things together very easily
you cannot unmix them that's because of
entropy in the second law of
thermodynamics and scientists have
understood it for over a hundred years
now what they don't understand is why
the universe in which we live has this
property that the entropy started so
small in the first place everything
around us is a reflection of entropy
going up the fact that you remember
yesterday but not tomorrow the fact that
you can make plans for tomorrow but not
for yesterday the fact that you grow
older the fact that you can mix things
together not unmix them this is all a
reflection of the fact that entropy is
going up but that means it started very
small and that's a question for
cosmology that's a statement about the
Big Bang what happened
14 billion years ago at the very
beginning of the universe the universe
is like a wind-up toy that started all
wound up and has been relaxed
singing moving around ever since and
eventually it will wind down the far
future one Google the years from now the
universe will stop moving everything
will just died out so why is that why
did the universe start near the Big Bang
in this wound-up state and the answer is
we don't know modern cosmology does not
know the answer to that question so in
my book from eternity to here I think
about different possible answers to that
question
you start with Einstein space-time what
time really means black holes wormholes
time travel we think about entropy and
lip-read Boltzmann that a slightly crazy
Austrian physicist who was the master of
entropy we talked about information
theory and complexity in the meaning of
life
quantum mechanics there are thought
experiments involving cats and dogs and
then we get to the universe and how
entropy works in the universe and just
like our cup of coffee is part of a
bigger system part of the kitchen which
is part of the solar system which is
part of the galaxy which is part of the
universe the best understanding of why
there's an arrow of time within our
universe is that our universe is not all
there is our universe could be part of a
much bigger multiverse and the way that
our universe came out of that multiverse
could help explain why the Big Bang was
so special why it had such a tiny
entropy we don't know the answer is
these are speculations that we're trying
to figure out how to test these ideas
but the great part of it is that we
start thinking about the cup of coffee
you start thinking about why we remember
yesterday and not tomorrow and from
taking these things seriously from
trying to understand the era of time
we're led to think about the very
furthest edges of the universe and maybe
even a little bit beyond